uh take one last call we'll get out of
here robin and uh we'll resume tomorrow
let's go to andy in georgia hi andy you
know i called you guys in 1982 from
norwalk connecticut yeah i remember you
oh yeah right
anyways i have a really good act i've
been doing stand-up for seven years i
sent the tape to agt
i was going to send you guys a tape and
have you evaluate it i'll watch them
but i'm going to be honest with you if
you're good i'll tell you but if you're
not i'll tell you too
and i don't want to destroy you and this
is the problem i had even with america's
got down most people that i meet
especially in america because i don't go
anywhere else
yeah everybody you meet is in america
everyone i meet is in my house honestly
i can be honest but this is a sad
reality if i watched your tape and i
said to you gee it's not very good and
here's why i would never say to you it's
not good i would tell you why i don't
think it's good yeah and then most
people give up they go [ __ ] i suck [ __ ]
it i'm gonna go get a regular job
i have been told many times in my life
that i suck on the on the radio in fact
just recently i was told that in fact
yesterday i was told that
but i never take no for an answer i
always believed in myself and i believed
that i had something to say and that i'd
be good to be on the radio so in a way i
hate to evaluate your tape because i
don't want you to give up how old are
you 67. perfect time to start
rodney dangerfield made it late in life
by late in life i mean in his 40s
grandma moses was around your age and
made it as a painter
now i'm a little edgy maybe for them for
instance you young people are in the
threesomes i would never do that who
needs two guys who don't know what
they're doing
i like that joke that's a good joke
all right here's one for you robin my
mother's annoying she's always giving me
this shitty advice she says it's better
to go to bed with a good book than a bad
man robin you try getting a kindle into
your vagina
you're good you got something
who's gonna tell me where to send it to
you and robin all right here's our
address spam siriusxm.com
i'll tell you what let me put you on
hold
and i will watch it okay oh you're a
doll thank you so much let me yeah get
the address yeah gary'll pick up
if i don't like the tape what i'm gonna
do and i'm being honest
i'm just gonna tell her i said you know
i forwarded your tape to jimmy kimmel
and he loved it well just tell her
you've forwarded it you can't tell her
what jimmy thought no i'm gonna do you
know that's what i'm gonna i'm gonna do
that i'm gonna say you know who loves
your tape jimmy kimmel here's his number
you call him about it
simple kimbo